allez ma petite cas est magie rendre au
temple à les jeunes disciples culotte
mois dépêchez-vous j'ai d'autres chats à
fouetter
non pas tant mon petit je veux dire que
j'ai du travail bâclé affaires brassées
sur le fps gaston lagaffe bon que son
fait là on s'ennuie à mourir pourrait
compliquer mourir bon comme les haricots
des mois vous avez un ferme et we all
avons trouvé une idée pour fêter les un
million d'abonnés
on pourrait balancer un million
météorite chez lui le mari
j'aime bien ce mec canon pour avant jc
pas comme ça qu'on va trouver un truc
bien on pourrait leur donner de l'espoir
en leur redonnant de l'espoir
ok je veux réagir
et puis vous étiez vous en fait je suis
la nuit je suis la lumière dans
l'obscurité qui éclaire cette ville je
suis la goutte de rosée sur la feuille
du présent je souhaite encore vous est
chiant et toi on te jure on a qu est née
des docks eu les statuts l'ambiance quoi
bon y'a personne n'a encore parlé par
diane canaille
moi lui dis pas de conneries jeudi le
conneries ici je veux te montrer ce que
j'ai dans ma poche des mouchoirs sont
pas censés se passer comme ça ah c'est
très impressionnant
je suis l'incarnation de l'espoir d'une
génération je suis le phare dans les
thématiques mélomanes à bin oui c'est
moi je suis là pris dans ta vie et
comment bien faire le mal en plein coeur
je suis le rouge
je vais vous tuer
comme j'ai tué toutes les franchises sur
lesquels je n'aurais jamais osé mon
homme a fermé bordel vous allez trop une
idée des call girls météorite un
génocide la justice les élèves ont couru
points mais tu as raison en fait c'est
lui qui a raison
ouais on veut juste dire merci en fait
merci à tous nos abonnés et aux autres
aussi de nous suivre depuis presque
quatre ans maintenant si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment grâce à vous
alors du fond du coeur merci
merci
pourquoi chaque pas parce que
normalement c'est moi qui coupe la
caméra et là tu es devant
ok
attentes et centre
non